here we go good morning to you I'm Gayle
King we're in the Toyota greenroom with
New York Times bestselling author what's
your name New York Times bestselling
author Angie Thomas Angie Thomas is her
name her first book was called the hate
you give was adapted into a critically
acclaimed film by the same name now
she's out with a new novel already she's
got a new novel it's called on the
come-up on the come-up 20th Century Fox
just announced it two will be adapted
into a movie welcome to you Angie Thomas
thank you so tell me what this is like
for you your first book is out it's a
it's a success gonna be a movie your
second book is out and they're already
talking about making it into a movie and
you're feeling what I feel like I'm
living a dream
I really do I feel like I'm gonna wake
up one day you know this is what little
Angie dreamed about in Mississippi what
did you dream about in Mississippi
Angie dreamed about telling stories and
seeing them come to life she would see
all these characters and things in her
head and she would write them down she
would tell her mom these stories and
she'd want to see them on screen one day
and what would mom say when she's
telling mom the story she would listen
courage you oh yeah yeah when I was like
around five years old if she was reading
like a story to me like she read for
green eggs and ham to me yeah I hate it
the way it ended though cuz I was like
why did he give in if he doesn't like it
he should still like it you thought that
at five yeah and so I told I was like
mommy no it should have went like I
still don't like green eggs and ham I
still don't like them sam-i-am because
she was like okay baby is it fair to say
that your rhyming started with dr. Seuss
you know now is it probably I mean I
never thought about it until you just
started green eggs and canned ham I
still don't like it Sam I am you know
here we have on the come-up we can go to
your Instagram to see your original
reaction when the book came because
number one I love seeing joy and other
people and you held up the book and you
said it's like my my baby has been born
yeah
and so this baby came from where you
know this baby came from a lot of long
hours and just thinking about stuff that
I went through when I was a teenager you
know after the hate you give I knew that
I wanted to do a story about hip hop and
then I also knew that I wanted to do
something to speak to kids even more so
in neighborhoods like my old one you
know
I thought about your old neighborhood
and what is it about hip-hop the story
that you wanted to tell what is your old
neighborhood my own I haven't been to
your house but what it is well you're
more than welcome to come I love to I
grew up in a neighborhood called
Georgetown back in Jackson Mississippi
is actually the same neighborhood where
Medgar Evers lived my mom was a little
girl when it happened she actually heard
the shots that killed him so that's how
close my house was to his and Georgetown
though after all of the civil rights
stuff Georgetown went down you know so
it was a neighborhood of gangs and drug
dealers I had heard gunshots every
single night but what hip-hop did for me
and for so many kids like me was they
were telling those stories that we
connected with and they made us feel
scene yeah you know when because the
stories of the day like what was out
when you were a little kid that you said
well that's not really my life like well
let's see I would have to say I remember
a lot of times teachers would give us a
little House on the Prairie
yeah and I have nothing against that but
I was like you know but there was one
book I did see myself in and I was roll
of thunder hear my cry and that was like
the only one but I had a hard time
connecting with books yeah so you said I
want to tell a story that I can relate
to yes and it was hip-hop yes because
hip-hop does what for for you and for
others it's people who love this genre
of music it tells our stories and it
gives us a voice you know I remember
hearing Tupac for the first time when I
was like eight years old which by the
way could you just for a second
should I take the shoe off yes okay
you're the first person I know that was
Tupac socks this late you call
commitment okay but good that about two
five yeah yeah and he was like I give a
holla to my sisters on welfare Tupac
cares if don't nobody else care and that
was deep for me because I was like Here
I am this poor kid and this guy I've
never met just says I care like that's
powerful
I felt seen I felt heard so for so many
kids like me that's what hip-hop did for
us and then when you had the world
saying you know like the majority saying
all this trash
is negative this and that that was like
telling us that our lives are trash
where your lives don't matter exactly
so hip-hop validated us yeah and at the
end of the day I think that's what
everybody wants is validation so I look
at you talk about validation
you're certainly validated on your
second first book and now your second
book did you feel pressure with your
second book since your first was such a
success I did initially it was all from
me you know I did it to myself
self-imposed oh yeah I'm my biggest
critic and I at first every time I wrote
a line it felt like thousands of eyes
were watching over my shoulder saying
star wouldn't say that start with the
character in the hate you get yes yeah
and I just had to get to the point of
saying well Bree says this and and and
I'm happy that I went through the
struggle because I learned to listen to
my own voice and my own author voice and
know that my instincts are good and I
can follow what I want to follow and
write what I want to write and write it
from me not from my readers yeah so I
tell them all the time I wasn't thinking
about you guys when I wrote this book
you were you were now in Brees head yeah
and I think it's interesting that you
had two different characters led to
strong female characters star in the
hate you give Bree and to come up and
but you they also had different family
dynamics which I thought was interesting
that there's a story behind that that
you wanted to tell too but I also think
is important absolutely for me it was
very important to show to young black
girls from the same neighborhood cuz I I
remember when I did you when did you
when I interviewed you yes for they hate
you give I was so excited that star came
from a nuclear family yes okay and on
the come-up bree does not yes and you
said but they're both very important yes
okay yes explain yes it was extremely
important because I wanted to show two
young ladies from the same neighborhood
whose lives aren't the same because so
often black girls are stereotyped
they're generalizations made we all are
angry exactly exactly all right you know
you all come from the same kind of house
yes and you have the same kind of
temperament and I wanted to show people
that that's not true and then with Brees
family being a bit dysfunctional at
times I wanted to say that even those
kids their stories deserve to be told so
you also I read something interesting
about anger you said anger is not
necessarily a bad thing what did you say
about that do you remember yeah yeah
yeah cuz I thought you know that that's
a message we need to put out go ahead
yeah you know because so often that
angry black girl or like one a
stereotype is used and it's used to make
us feel as if we can't be angry but
there's nothing wrong with being angry
that doesn't mean we're being illogical
that doesn't mean you're rational
exactly that doesn't mean that what
we're feeling isn't relevant so we
should be able to have our anger I say
it man get to be angry all the time so
why can't we yeah and sometimes anger is
also very important and dare I say
justified
yes let's talk about Brees character
though because she she's first explained
I actually know what it means but for
those of you who don't
what does on the come-up mean and for
this book it has two meanings for me
wine only no one okay I'll tell you the
first thing when someone says they're on
the come-up that means they're on the
verge of making it you're on the verge
of that's what I know yeah yeah but in
the South we say someone's coming up as
a way of saying they're growing up so
I'm saying she's on the verge of growing
up this is her coming-of-age tale okay
and Bree has always wanted to be a
rapper her father is dead she didn't
really know her father and he was killed
but he was a very was a legendary rapper
in the area and so she wants to be a
rapper but not necessarily because of
her father right she actually loves
rapping right right it's her passion to
is her way of expressing herself and and
it was important for me even in a sense
of here's this young lady who's going
into an industry that's so
male-dominated for her to have her own
reason for wanting to do it that has
nothing to do with her dad and she wants
to establish herself apart from him so
it's in some ways it's almost an analogy
of what it's like to be a young woman in
hip-hop when you have the forefathers of
the darkness glaring down at you based
on like why are you worthy like in
Murray's room hanging on her wall yes
Queen Latifah Missy Elliott MC Lyte
cardi Nicki she's got them both she
doesn't believe in the beef she's she
was in between them it's like the
Queen's of hip-hop looking down on her
yes and so there's sort of an
inspiration to her every day yes you
know the other thing you did that I
thought was interesting is that you gave
us some insight into how rap works for
BRE and could you talk about that
because I was very fascinated by the way
you wrote it you could see words coming
out of her head and now she would pair
one with the other with the other with
the other and then in the very next page
you showed us how she put it all
together yeah that was cool thank you
thank you you know that was hard to do
well explain what you did well for me I
would try to come up with the raps
myself ahead of time and then I look
back over at them and say okay what's
her purpose for this word I wanted every
word to have purpose because I wanted to
take it seriously because rappers take
it seriously I wanted to respect the
craft and so it was it was important for
me to not just have her doing words and
without meaning behind them so that my
readers can even see there's purpose so
that hopefully they will actually listen
to rap songs and relax huh
there's a reason Kendrick rhymed that
with that there's a reason J Cole did
that with that I'm trying to find a
partner book do you remember where you
sort of laid out something for us like
sister could rhyme with I thought I
never thought about rhyming but do you
remember the part I'm talking about I
think towards the end yeah but I dunno -
like in the beginning - okay let's do
that like when she's doing the battle
rap and she's thinking about it she's
like Here I am coming to him as if I
don't have any manners yes well come on
with manners cameras hammer pamper you
know and stuff like that and she's like
hammer MC Hammer
people don't consider him a real rapper
some people don't you know who was
another one Vanilla Ice and she stars
Ram Ronnie stuff with that and so she
wants to connect every single line so
that it tells us Craig no I did like
that so can you do that and the one that
you did define you're supposed to know
it off the top of your head I don't know
it actually I do
I did okay cuz I start as it goes my
apology see I forgot my manners I get on
the mic cuz it's my life you show off
for girls and cameras you a pop star not
a rapper
Vanilla Ice or a hammer I had his mess
he dumped it now somebody get him a
pamper yeah you even tell your people
ooh and then put their hand also and the
other part I liked is that you said you
can't have brie with no Brill you can't
have Brie you cannot breathe without
brilliant yes do you remember how you
use that interrupts because I thought
that was good - yeah you can only say
brilliant by first day and breathe yeah
can you say with Gail Gail Oh Jo wait
there a good word would you mean have
something here you Mull that over next
time I love you you come a little come
on because I thought that was so good
you can't have brilliant without
briefers I love that so also there's
there's a little love interest in this
book yes are you telling us about your
life zero is there a Malik or young man
we won't spoil um you know I know I
don't say the name for that Mary I did
when I was at that age and it was it was
important for me to show what it's like
to eat them as you're growing up what
does it mean when you're growing up and
you're maybe growing apart yeah so yeah
you know I get asked that even about
what the hate you give and Chris you're
like was there Chris yeah is there a
Chris or a Malik or the other we can
speak to on this date February 5th not
today no I do not want to say because
mom is here people are watching or you
want to share it later not right now I
gots to go all I can say to you is
congratulation last time you said you
were living in Jackson Mississippi yes
then you wanted to stay there your
hometown because you wanted people to be
able to see you or are you still in
Jackson Mississippi yeah for now for now
so you are open to moving yeah I have an
interesting relationship with
Mississippi
someone wants describe Mississippi as
being a parent of abusive emotionally
abusive parent yeah you know that you
know you love them but sometimes you
wonder if they love you yeah but you
know Oprah's from Mississippi as you
know and she also often talks about it
was the most segregated state in the
country that she came from that state to
be who she is so I understand how it can
be a complicated relationship yes all I
can say is I'm cheering you on
I can't wait to see what you do next but
I will definitely go see on the come-up
and in the movie theater thank you
Congrats to you thank you Oh who's
directing George Tillman again who
directed again yes I think you got your
chair bonded oh yeah yeah George is
awesome and always do it well with Gail
you always do what's again always do it
well with you
like karna bronze when she did it Angie
thank you on the come-up is on sale
right now wherever you like to buy your
books